bienvenidos de nuevo nos quedamos en el
problema número 7 así que vamos a
resolverlo el problema número 7
estamos en la sección número 8 en el
examen número 7 y este es el problema
número 7 ok y dice lo siguiente la
rutina de ejercicio diario de dalián
consiste en nadar andar en bicicleta y
correr en ese orden
ok creo que eso será importante así que
lo voy a contar una vez consiste en
nadar lo voy a poner un color azul en
nadar después a andar en bicicleta o
andar en bicicleta ok
borrar la bicicleta va a dar después va
a andar en bicicleta y por último va a
correr y por último va a correr en ese
orden entonces primero éste después anda
en bicicleta y por último corre dice
ella corre más rápido de lo que nada
ella corre y no me puede decir ella
corre más rápido de lo que nada y
después nos dice que ella anda en bici
más rápido de lo que corre como todos
nosotros ella anda en bici más rápido de
lo que corre del lujo si no descansa
entre las actividades cuál de las
siguientes podría ser la gráfica de la
distancia recorrida en total durante
todo el tiempo de su rutina diaria ok
voy a pensar en la distancia contra
tiempo así que déjenme hacer aquí
antes de los sencillos un plano
cartesiano lo voy a hacer más o menos
así y más o menos así y vamos a ver si
podemos llegar a una conclusión
muy bien este va a ser mi eje de la
distancia distancia y aquí me voy a
tomar un viaje
del tiempo del tiempo
de lujo ok ahora imagínate que tú eres
dalia y empiezas nadando como nadas más
rápido de hecho nada es más lento de lo
que corres y andas en bici más rápido de
lo que corres lo que más lento haces es
nadar eso quiere decir que en distancia
contra tiempo vas a tener una recta con
pendiente muy pequeña imagínate que
tienes una pendiente más o menos así es
más déjame cambiar de herramienta
tienes una pendiente muy pequeña
entonces vas a empezar con algo así eso
quiere decir que tu velocidad es pequeña
a un cierto tiempo se recorre una
distancia pequeña ahora imagínate que
después justo en ese momento dejas de
nadar y empiezas a andar en bicicleta y
se empieza a andar en bicicleta es lo
que más rápido haces aquí dice que la
bicicleta es lo que más rápido hacemos
por lo tanto la distancia contra tiempo
va a ser una recta
a una pendiente muy grande va a ser algo
así eso quiere decir que en un tiempo
muy pequeño vas a recorrer una distancia
muy grande ok o dicho de otra manera tía
es una velocidad muy grande y después
justo en ese momento te bajes de la
bicicleta y empiece a correr y empieza a
correr y es lo que haces en una
velocidad media si te das cuenta la
velocidad más pequeña es nadar después
sigue correr y después la bicicleta por
lo tanto aquí tienes una recta con
pendiente media algo más o menos así
esto quiere decir que en un cierto
tiempo medio pasa a recorrer una
distancia media ok y entonces ya tendría
más o menos la gráfica de la distancia
contra el tiempo de estas tres
actividades primero nada si tienes una
velocidad pequeña después ans en bici y
distancia de media y por último corres y
tienes una velocidad más grande ok y si
te das cuenta la única gráfica que se
parece a esto es el inciso
el éxito es la única gráfica que se
parece a esta gráfica de aquí por
ejemplo en am va lento después pasas al
medio y después a rápido esto no
funciona eso quiere decir que la bici
estaría hasta el final y eso no puede
ser cierto porque sabemos que la bici
está en medio después por ejemplo
tenemos en el inciso b a los lento hasta
el final lo que quiere decir que hasta
el final nada harías
y eso no es cierto en el c lo mismo y en
el de ella al en bicing después nada
después corre lo cual no es cierto
primero era nadar después de andar en
bici y después correr en fin creo que la
única respuesta correcta y lo que más se
asemeja a esta gráfica de aquí es el
insisto en nada si andas en bici corres
ok y si suben vamos al problema número 8
déjame borrar la pantalla y vamos a
trabajar con el problema número 8 que
dice en el plano cartesiano x ya raíz de
6 comarca y ese punto es importante
a raíz de 6,1 que es uno de los puntos
de la intersección de las siguientes
gráficas y es igual a equis cuadrada
menos 7 ok y la otra gráfica es james es
igual a menos x cuadrada más j
y justo lo que me preguntan es cuánto
vale jota y lo que quiero saber es el
valor de j
ok bueno este punto es el punto de
intersección entre estas dos gráficas
eso quiere decir que este punto de aquí
vive tanto en esta gráfica como en esta
gráfica eso dicho de otra manera quiere
decir que para el mismo valor en x se va
a cumplir el mismo valor en 10 justo en
ese punto en ambas gráficas y bueno eso
lo podemos ocupar utilizando o haciendo
una ecuación que ecuación que en este
punto se cumple que ya que esta ley es
igual es igual a la otra y hasta el 10
de camps porque en ese punto se
interceptan a ambas gráficas por lo
tanto los dos valores de los dos valores
de x son iguales pero en esta gráfica de
verden es lo mismo que x cuadrada x
cuadrada menos 7 ok esto pensando en que
se intersectan en este punto en el punto
de raíz de 6 como acá esto tiene que ser
igual
pues la otra función y la otra función
es menos x cuadrada
j y si te das cuenta de aquí ya vamos a
poder obtener el valor de j
estamos muy cerca de obtenerlo porque
porque nosotros sabemos cuánto vale x en
este punto
en este punto x vale a raíz de 6
entonces voy a sustituir esta raíz de 6
tanto aquí como la voy a sustituir justo
acá y que me va a quedar raíz de 6 al
cuadrado lo cual por cierto es 6 menos 7
esto es igual a menos la raíz de 6 al
cuadrado lo cual es 6
recuerda que la raíz de 6 elevado al
cuadrado está cuando éste se va y me
queda simple y sencillamente 6 de lujo
ahora cumplió el valor de jota qué te
parece si es 16 de ambos lados de esta
ecuación y aquí voy a sumar 6 ok con
digamos de color + 6 y aquí también voy
a sumar 6 y me va a quedar que j&j es
igual a 6 6 -7 lo cual es
12 - 7 lo cual es 5 el valor de jota que
nosotros estábamos buscando es 5 y esto
lo obtuvimos igualando estas dos
ecuaciones y utilizando que estas dos
cuestiones son iguales en un punto en
este punto que me dan ok y entonces
vamos a ver nuestros sencillos y es el
inciso a de lujo el problema número 8 no
estaba tan difícil vamos el problema
número
problema número 9 y me dice lo siguiente
problema número 9 el valor absoluto de 2
- x
esto es menor que 3 esto es menor que 3
que lo que me preguntan es cuál los
siguientes insisto puede ser un valor
factible para x ok
vamos a trabajar con desigualdades de
valor absoluto y lo que quiero que
recuerden es que esto lo podemos ver de
dos maneras tomarme esto de aquí ya
quitando el valor absoluto es
equivalente esto es equivalente a decir
que 2 - x esto está entre 3
-3 ok esto es una expresión equivalente
a la otra y la que a mí me gusta más es
pensando como distancia eso quiere decir
que la distancia que hay de 2x es menor
que 3 dicho de otra manera esto lo
podemos escribir como que 2 - x la
instancia de 12 x tiene que ser menor
que 3 o ayudando caso esto es lo mismo
que pensar que x menos 2 la distancia
que hay de x2 tiene que ser menor que 3
o la distancia que hay de 2x es menor
que 3 o disfrutar manera la distancia de
x a 2 debe ser menor que 3 muy bien y de
aquí podemos despejar en x de esta
primera de esta primera si yo despejó x
me va a quedar que ha sumando x de ambos
lados ok vamos a sumar x voy a sumar x
aquí ok
luisma x aquí
y esto se va y me queda que dos es más
pequeño que tres más equis y ahora si
restó tres de ambos lados de esta
desigualdad me queda que menos 1 es
menor que x ok esto en primer lugar pero
vamos a ver qué me dice ahora esta
ecuación aquí si yo paso este menos dos
del otro lado me va a quedar que x es
menor que 5 ok y bueno como estamos
hablando de una desigualdad de valor
absoluto esto quiere decir que x tiene
que estar entre menos uno y cinco y de
hecho esto también lo podemos ver con la
siguiente expresión con este de aquí si
nosotros pensamos justo en esto vamos a
llegar a lo mismo primero voy a restar
dos de todos los lados de esta
desigualdad me va a quedar que menos 5
es menor que menos x que es menor que
tres menos 2 es 1 ok y ahora se
multiplicó todo todo esto por menos 1
entonces me va a quedar que 5 es más
grande recuerda que cuando multiplicas
por un número negativo o divides entre
el número negativo la desigualdad se
voltean 5 es más grande que x que a su
vez es más grande que menos 1
multiplicando todo por menos 1 ok esto
dicho de otra manera me queda que menos
1 es más pequeño que x que es más
pequeño que 5 llegamos a lo mismo que x
tiene que estar entre 5 y menos 1 entre
menos uno y 5 ok y si te das cuenta en
todos mis sencillos el único número que
está entre menos uno y cinco es a enciso
am que es 4 este es el único que está
entre menos uno y cinco y bueno de hecho
si no te acuerdas de toda esta teoría
que es muy importante que tú te prendas
de valor absoluto inclusive podrías
tener todos tus incisos y
que realmente sirva esta desigualdad de
un principio y si nosotros metemos que x
vale 4 vamos a llegar a que esto es
cierto vamos a ver dos menos cuatro es
menos dos y me quedaría que el valor
absoluto de menos 2
esto es menor que 3 lo cual es cierto
aquí dice que 2 es menor que 3 y esto es
cierto ya está la respuesta de este
problema número 9 es a insisto a que
vale 4 ok
volvemos la pantalla y yo creo que le
voy a parar justo aquí porque siguiente
problema tiene la gráfica de un polígono
y prefiero hacerlo con kallman para
presentárselo en el siguiente vídeo así
que mejor le seguimos en el siguiente
vídeo con el problema número 10 hasta la
próxima